a new poll shows Americans aren't that
proud of their country the Supreme Court
race heats up and president Trump goes
to war on trade i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
well it's the day before fourth of July
my favorite holiday of the year fourth
of July is just spectacular of course
and we'll do some fourth of July talk
today we will also talk about why you
should be proud to be an American
because at least you know you're free
but we begin today first with our
friends over at software advice so the
reality is that you have experts
available to you on pretty much any
subject under the Sun except for the
software that you use for your business
and this is one of the most important
things that you can do for your business
is have updated software have the
programs that you need that are going to
ensure that your business runs as
efficiently as humanly possible but you
don't have anybody to go - well that's
what software advice does for you
they've done all the research their team
of advisers can point you in the right
direction so you can start working more
effectively right away and it's
absolutely free just go to software
advice comm slash Ben you answer a few
short questions about your business and
then you are connected with an advisor
to discuss the best software options for
your needs and talking to an advisor
just takes ten minutes or less whether
you're a medical professional or a
construction manager and HR pro software
advice helps you save time and money and
make you a more informed decision so if
you're an entrepreneur or if you work
solo software advice is what you need
experts are ready to be on-call they're
your on-call go-to team they help you
figure out business software in minutes
for free it's a really easy solution to
this problem that you've been scratching
your head over and the software struggle
go to software advice comm slash Bend to
get started that software advice.com
slash pens connects with an advisor for
free software advice.com slash men
whether it's tailored software program
or generic software advice comm knows
what you need software advice calm slash
Bend use that slash pens let them know
that we sent you okay so there's a new
poll out today on the eve of July 4th
and it's pretty discouraging the poll
suggests that less than half of all US
adults are extremely proud to be
American and when you can find that
question to Democrats that number Falls
to less than a third less than a third
under one and three Democrats are
extremely proud to be Americans now I
know there were similar polls taken
during the Obama era Republicans still
said they were proud to be American they
just didn't like President Obama
Democrats tend to believe that the
leadership of the country is reflective
of the country itself so when there's
the president that they like like Barack
Obama then they're very proud of their
country and when there's president they
don't like like George aid should like
george w bush or like donald trump then
they are not so fond of our country
they're not extremely
proud of their country I'm proud of my
country having nothing nothing to do
with who the president is because my
country is not the president my country
is not the people who currently
constitute the government my country is
the country based on the Declaration of
Independence in the Constitution and the
philosophy that underlies that my
country is the country with a shared
common history and a shared common value
right that's that's the country that I
care about and if you don't see America
as a set of eternal principles and
values that outlive any single president
or any single legislature or any single
Speaker of the House or any single
Supreme Court justice I would suggest
that you don't have a valuable view of
America in and of itself you just think
of America as what it is today
as opposed to America as a manifestation
of the of certain ideals and maybe those
ideals are being imperfectly implemented
but that doesn't mean you shouldn't be
proud of the ideals themselves or the
history of America which has freed more
people from tyranny than any country in
the history of the globe Republicans
have consistently said they are
extremely proud to be American had a
significantly higher rate than Democrats
according to media I the this new number
that less than half of all Americans are
extremely proud to be American this is a
new low since the question was first
poll by Gallup in 2003 overall 47% of US
adults are extremely proud among
Democrats at numbers 32% Republicans
have said they are extremely proud much
more consistently than Democrats because
Republicans are much more tied to
foundational documents and to the system
created by the Constitution and the
Declaration of Independence also
Republicans are more likely to engage in
displays of patriotism there are a lot
of good studies that suggest that if you
take your kid to a 4th of July parade
that in and of itself is a good
predictor as to whether your kid will
vote Republican or Democrat because if
you feel there is inherent importance to
the idea of America and to the symbolism
of America you're more likely to be
Republican or as if you think of
yourself as a global citizen as a person
who's above and beyond these American
ideals you're a person who can stand
outside America and cast a keen eye at
the problems in America faces you're
more likely to be a Democrat the number
dipped slightly to 68% of Republicans
saying they were extremely proud to be
American in 2016 but it's now 74 percent
Democrats conversely said they were
extremely proud irate of 46 percent in
2016 but in two years that number has
dropped by fourteen points and that's
obvious why that's because Republicans
now dominate public politics so as
Republicans have continued to dominate
electoral Democrats have become
unless proud of their country because
again Democrats think of America as the
government they don't think of it as the
American people or the values embodied
by the American people
or the founding values which they don't
like anyway Democrats believe that the
founding values merely enshrined racism
sexism bigotry and homophobia that all
of the Constitution all of the
Declaration of Independence was written
as a way to enshrine property ownership
by rich white men this is the Howard
Zinn view of history and unfortunately
it's permeated a large segments of the
Democratic Party it's a real problem for
Democrats it really is because most
Americans generally despite this poll
most Americans still kind of like the
country and when you have this Howard
Zinn view of history that George
Washington was just a rich white
slave-owner who had no principles and
then he wasn't risking anything in the
Revolutionary where all these guys just
wanted to keep their own property when
you believe that you throw out American
history when you treat American history
is just a series of power relations what
you're really doing is undermining what
America is and what makes America good
the reality is that America is the only
country in human history founded on an
ideal a stated ideal and a good ideal
the idea that all men are created equal
granted inalienable rights by their
creator a that is a unique proposition
in human history and the founding
fathers may not have perfectly realized
the manifestation of that idea right
slavery still existed obviously many of
the same people who signed the
Declaration of Independence the guy who
wrote the Declaration of Independence
was a slave holder but it doesn't mean
that the ideal that they were promoting
wasn't a good ideal it was a great ideal
it is a great ideal and that's why I've
always objected to the folks who kneel
during the national anthem I've always
objected to this idea that you have to
burn the flag in order to protest it
seems to me the way you really should be
doing is saying I love the flag and
that's why I think that we're not
standing up in proper ways for it
I love the national anthem I love the
country and that's why I think that we
have to fulfill that dream this is what
Frederick Douglass did so well he did a
very famous speech during the the late
days of slavery before the Civil War he
did a speech very famous fourth of July
speech in which he said the Declaration
of Independence is magnificent document
but it doesn't protect people like me it
should protect people like me it should
be universal let's look at the universal
implications of the ideas pushed by
Thomas Jefferson and then let's go out
and act upon them right that's the way
that people ought to question whether
we're living up to our own ideals the
ideal
themselves are good and this this
Marxist idea that all politics all
principle is really just a manifestation
of what you want it's all just power
relationships that the only reason that
the Constitution exists is because
they're a bunch of people who want to
preserve their own interests it's just
not correct it's just not correct it was
a lot riskier for the founders to fight
against the greatest empire on earth
than it was for them it was much riskier
for them to fight that that Empire and
put all their property at risk I mean
the Declaration of Independence pledges
their lives they're there their wealth
and their sacred honor their lives their
fortunes and their sacred honor to the
fight there are their founders who won't
legitimately broke in the course of the
Revolutionary War robert Livingston
among them from New York he watched his
house burned to the ground that George
Washington there's there's a story of my
business partner german-born was telling
me last night hey George Washington the
the British were threatening Mount
Vernon and apparently one of his one of
his staffers basically went out and
begged the British not to burn down
Mount Vernon when Washington found out
about who's angry he said listen I
pledged my life my fortune my sacred
honor to fight this battle to pretend
that the heroes of America's past are
not actually heroes is deeply embedded
in a lot of democratic ideology right
now and it's really bad it means that
there's no commonality you want to know
why the country is breaking apart
because we don't have a common mythology
we don't have a common set of values we
don't have a common concept of Liberty
even the things that you see unites us
divide us go back to 1950 and listen to
how Democrats talked about the
Declaration of Independence look at the
speeches and the writings of Arthur
Schlessinger and who is considered your
the great intellectual of the Democratic
Party look at the speeches of JFK
there's a lot of patriotism to Democrats
in the nineteen twenties thirties
forties fifties sixties then in the
sixties it broke and the sixties it was
decided that America was actually a bad
place and that all of the evils that
were obvious in American life were
simply parts of a greater horrible
hierarchy that they were effects of this
terrible American hierarchy that the
reason that there was racism the reason
there was Jim Crow the reason there was
this war in Vietnam it was all because
America had been built on the wrong
basis if it had been built on the basis
of redistributionist Marxism with social
ownership of the means of production
then everything would have been so much
better and the left has never gotten
over this
so according to this report from Gallup
politics appears to be a factor in and
why so many people are not proud to be
American with sharp declines evidence
among Democrats and political liberals
and no decrease among Republicans and
conservatives but that's the point right
the the point here is not that Democrats
dropped their support for the United
States because it from what's in what's
actually kind of interesting is that
Republicans support for the United
States or enthusiasm about the United
States only rose like a little bit in
single digits in other words Republicans
are very much tied to these these
generalized ideals and Democrats see
these generalized ideals are as bad
unless they have a president in office
who's fighting against those generalized
ideals
the report says left-leaning group's
antipathy toward Trump and their belief
that other countries look unfavorably on
the president are likely factors in
their decline in patriotism particularly
the sharp drops in the last year but
again I point out the fact that I'm only
a minority of Democrats said they were
extremely proud to be American even when
Barack Obama was president what's it
that's a shocking statistic it's a
shocking statistic
I think there's there something else
happening too and that is that there are
a number of people who are just not
appreciative of living in America
because they have it so good
see it's everyone who's trying to get
into America realizes that America is a
great place everybody was trying to get
in illegally or legally
who's trying to cross that border is
trying to get here because it's better
here people around the world are trying
to imitate the implementation of
American markets and American
constitutional ideas because they see
that America is a powerhouse and they
look at their own lives and they say our
own life isn't that great maybe our life
could be better if we started
implementing some of those ideals and in
fact when you implement those ideals
your country becomes better when you
implement free market ideas on a rock
like Hong Kong you turn Hong Kong into a
thriving place when you implement
terrible ideas in an apparent area then
you end up in poverty so one of the
things that's important to note here is
that we are all living better in the
United States and generally around the
world than we ever have Bill Gates is
right he's the obviously Microsoft
co-founder and he's praised the
republican-led Congress for rejecting
the Trump administration's proposed cuts
to the State Department budget according
to PJ Media Gates pointed out that the
foreign aid budget nearly doubled during
President George HW Bush's tenure but
here's the point that he makes and this
is this is the one that I think actually
matters he says
that the world is better now than it
ever has been it's not really about how
much we spent on foreign aid this is
where he's wrong but he says that the
world is a far better place than it ever
has been in history and that is
essentially true I mean materially that
is certainly true he says by almost any
metric the world is a far better place
today less violent deaths less disease
more education than ever in its history
it doesn't mean that we can feel
complacent about that remaining burden
he noted that in that in 1990 12 million
kids under five years old died that
figures now less than 5 million per year
the world he said is a hundred times
less violent than it was a thousand
years ago that is the percentage of
deaths that are violent is down
dramatically
so attitudes have shifted obviously the
world is a better place and I would
suggest the reason the world's a better
place is because of murica the reason
the world is a better place is because
of the United States in a second I'm
going to talk about that a little bit
more first I want to say thanks to the
u.s. ECA so one of the things that the
United States is always enshrined is the
Second Amendment and as we approach 4th
of July it's important to remember that
one of the reasons that we have our
freedoms is because American citizens
owned guns and you should own a gun too
if you're a law-abiding citizen you
should protect your family and your
community in your country with those
weapons so like me the u.s. EC it
believes the right to defend your loved
ones with a gun is a god-given freedom
and in honor of the 4th of July the US
ECA is celebrating our forefathers and
our Second Amendment freedom with the
great American giveaway five lucky
winners will each receive 1776 bucks to
purchase the gun and ammo of their
choice it's really easy just go to
defend your family now calm for your
free entry and then you can choose your
gun
Ruger Kimbra ar-15 no matter what you
choose you can get a really great gun
and still have money left over for the
ammo instead of drawing just one winner
they are drawing 5 which means you have
5 chances to win all you have to do is
go to defend your family now.com to get
entered your entry to win is 1772 in
1776 bucks for guns and ammo it's quick
it's simple it's free just go to defend
your family now calm let's defend your
family now calm you SCCA does great work
educating gun owners providing them with
all the legal the legal help that they
need in case they actually have to fire
a gun defend your family now calm check
it out defend your family now calm for
your chance to win 1776 bucks for a gun
and ammo of your choice again its defend
your family now calm ok so Bill Gates
says the worlds apart better place today
and then he doesn't really talk about
why he says that it must be because of
the US State Department
that's not why the world is a better
place the world is a better place
because the rest of the world has
embraced America's visions of markets
engaged with the United States in an
exchange of free labor because the rest
of the world has decided that America
had it right in the first place America
has been the Atlas holding up the world
since World War two it's virtually all
global growth has occurred on the back
of the United States there are a lot of
people on the Left who believe that if
the United States were to disappear or
foot were to go european-style
redistributionist or if they were to go
socialist then nothing in the world
would really change
well they neglect to mention is the fact
that the world the engine for growth is
the United States that is the engine of
growth in virtually every part of the
globe we are the chief trading partners
with a huge number of countries for a
reason we're not just the big of market
the biggest market or the biggest
producers the United States is a global
engine of growth not just because of
free markets but because of the values
embedded in free markets the idea that
you own your own labor the idea that you
have a duty and a responsibility to go
out and work hey these are American
ideas embedded in the Declaration of
Independence embedded in the
Constitution of the United States this
is all stuff we should be proud of when
we look at the world you know there's
there's a tendency by even some on the
right to look at the world we say well
you know America hasn't seen the gains
that it should have seen over the past
thirty years which I think is utter
nonsense
if you look at the standard of living in
the United States the stuff that you can
have now versus what you could have
thirty years ago you would significantly
rather live now than then live in 1980
but if you've got to be born when I was
born or be born now you'd rather be born
now it's just a reality and I'm only 34
the world has gotten to be a better
place since then but even if you believe
that even if you believe that the United
States has it has not grown the way that
it should and then you look at global
growth and you say well look at all
these other countries that are growing
so fast that's due to American power
that's due to the fact that America is
the greatest force for good in the
history of the world so if you're a
leftist and you don't actually believe
that a stronger America is necessary
look at the rest of the world where we
have half to the extreme poverty rate in
less than 40 years and think to yourself
maybe that's because the ideas that
created the United States were the best
ideas that anybody ever had for founding
a country and if you don't believe that
I think that you're going to get America
wrong you're not gonna be patriotic and
you're not going
understand why it is that America is is
great in the first place it's not just
that we have to make America great again
it's that we have to understand why
America was great in the first place so
that we can make America great again
okay meanwhile speaking of making
America great again the presidents of
the United States is moving steadily
toward picking his Supreme Court nominee
right now they are saying that the the
person in the lead is Judge Cavanaugh
from the DC Circuit Court of Appeals
I've said that I am rather skeptical of
judge Cavanaugh I don't think that he's
going to be justice Kennedy I don't
think he's going to be somebody who
veers wildly left but I certainly think
that there's a possibility he could be
judge Justice Roberts Chief Justice
Roberts the reason I say this is there a
couple of cases in which he ruled in
shall we say too clever by half fashion
so he's a brilliant guy Cavanaugh
there's no question I mean look at his
writing he's a great writer very very
smart legal theorist but one of the
problems I see is that there are two
types of votes on the Supreme Court
there's the Clarence Thomas kind of vote
on the Supreme Court which is I will
vote the way that I think is correct in
every possible case and I'm not going to
try to pretend that I'm currying favor
or cultivating votes among other members
of the court I'm not interested in the
cohesiveness Oh Court of gore coherence
or the or these sort of collegiality of
the court I'm more interested in just
voting the right way and saying what's
true which is Clarence Thomas's approach
and then there's Roberts's approach
which is I'm going to try to cobble
together majorities now sometimes you
need to cobble together majorities on
crucial cases but Roberts has a tendency
to do that by sacrificing principles so
I think most recently there's a case in
this term with regard to masterpiece
cake shop in which there were certainly
five votes certainly five votes to say
that laws that tell religious people
that they have to cater same-sex
weddings are discriminatory against
religious people and instead Roberts
decided I'm going to cobble together a
seven two opinion that is decided on
very narrow grounds where maybe those
laws aren't unconstitutional it's just
that they have to be implemented in the
most neutral possible way and that to me
is a mistake I think Kavanagh is more
along the lines of Roberts it seems to
me that he's somebody who's trying to
heat rise to do some consensus-building
there's a there's one particular there
are a couple particular cases for for a
Kavanagh that are sort of troubling
again if he's if he's nominated he will
be confirmed it's it but he but
the case the one that that is that is
most troubling is seven skies there's a
case called seven sky this is known
about the Obamacare case and in that
case he didn't go along with with the
opinion that Obamacare itself was
unconstitutional instead what he said is
I'm not going to rule on whether
Obamacare is unconstitutional because
under the anti-injunction Act I'm not
allowed to rule on whether Obamacare is
unconstitutional because basically the
penalty under Obamacare is applied as
attach and and be because the
anti-injunction Act is sort of
specifically worded I therefore I can't
reach the jurisdictional question yeah
that logic that this was a tax and not a
penalty ended up being used by Chief
Justice Roberts and by the Obama
administration in their arguments before
the Supreme Court that ended with Chief
Justice Roberts essentially
green-lighting Obamacare also there
there have been some complaints that
that Cavanaugh has been providing some
of his clerks to liberal justices at the
Supreme Court and there's more crossover
appeal to Cavanaugh for sure with other
leftist members of the court then there
are a couple of other cases that people
are talking about one is called priests
for life another is called Garza the
both both cases are I would say at least
slightly troubling none of this is to
say the Kavanagh is is going to be again
a wild liberal but it is to say that he
has a tendency to be too clever in his
rulings at least on the DC Circuit Court
of Appeals so it's some you know I'm I'm
not in love with this I'm just I'm not
in love with the Cavanaugh Peck I'm not
gonna pretend I'm supremely enthusiastic
about the Cavanaugh Peck I don't think
that it is it is going to again do I do
I think it's gonna be the worst thing in
the world no but I also think that it's
gonna fall well in line with the with
the generalized mainstream Republican
opinion now that we shouldn't overturn
roe v wade I don't think the Cavanaugh
will be a vote overturn Roe hey just my
speculation I don't think he will I
think a me koni Barrett well the other
possibility that Trump is considering
that will be and here's why I think this
case of Leonard Leo who's the head of
the Federalist Society which is a great
group I was a member in law school
Leonard Leo he came forward he said
listen we're probably not going to
overturn Roe okay this is the guy who is
the strongest advocate for Cavanaugh
right now he's the guy really pushing
for Cavanaugh and he's saying we're not
gonna overturn roe v wade which by the
way ought to be overturned
okay I'm saying it's straight out of
course it ought to be overturn to take
garbage to say
it is a bad legal decision it is a bad
moral decision it has nothing to it the
Constitution but Leonard Leo the guy
who's actually helping Trump select the
Supreme Court pick is saying openly he
doesn't think that roe v-- wade is gonna
be able to turn you know he's never
asked this question of a nominee we've
never discussed it and right now there's
only one justice on the court Clarence
Thomas who is said explicitly he wants
to overturn Roe so there's a lot of
speculation going on here and I'm just
very skeptical about you know what
people are suggesting might happen so
you know if you're getting that from
Leonard Leo then I would think that
that's probably the way that it's gonna
go it's it's worth noting by the way
that he was instrumental Cavanaugh was
when he was working with the Bush
administration and helping to push Chief
Justice Roberts on to the Supreme Court
in the first place now I understand
there's a tendency to try and you know
make people feel a little bit more
sanguine about whatever Supreme Court
pick happens here but this is not a time
to make people feel sanguine just go for
broke just go for the guy you want go
for the woman you want go for the person
you want who's going to rule the right
way on these cases why I've been
suggesting Mike Lee all the way I know
that Mike Lee is going to vote the right
way on these cases because I have
discussed constitutional jurisprudence
with Mike Lee because I know where Mike
Lee stands on key issues I don't know
why you would possibly risk it with a
mystery justice who may or may not vote
the way that you want on these issues
and this is one of those areas where I
think that it's it's too bad that
President Trump doesn't take a higher
level of interest I think that he's
farming it out too when a Leonard Leo
and Don McGann his White House Counsel I
just don't see that as a particularly
strong move okay in just a second I want
to talk about Alan Dershowitz and and
incivility first I want to say thanks to
our sponsors over at blinds.com so
there's one part of your house you
really don't think about a lot and it
seems irrelevant but then when you think
about it then when you change it it
makes your house a lot better and I'm
not talking about repainting the place
or building an addition I'm talking
about the blinds on your windows you
don't think about those a lot because
who the hell thinks about their blinds
but when you look at them go home look
your window coverings and they're gonna
be pretty ugly
I'm just good good indicator they're
probably gonna be pretty ugly that's why
you need blinds calm and taking the time
to pick out and buy blinds it sounds
expensive and kind of boring installing
them yourself sounds harder then you
want to admit but blinds.com makes it
super easy if you're not sure what you
want or where to start
wines calm it gives you a free online
design consultation
you send them pictures of your home they
send back custom recommendations from a
professional from what's gonna work with
your color scheme your furniture
specific rooms they'll even send you
free samples to make sure everything
looks as good in person as it does
online every single order gets free
shipping as well and here's the best
part the best part if you screw it up
right it's your fault you accidentally
miss measure you pick the wrong color
blinds calm will remake your blinds for
free they've made it really easy for you
there's no excuse to leave up those
mangled blinds that make it look like
you're you know from a trailer park in
the 1970s for a limited time get 20% off
everything at blinds comm when you use
promo code Ben that's blinds.com promo
code Ben for 20% off everything that's
faux wood blinds cellular shades roller
shades and more blinds kaam promo club
and use that promo code Ben so they know
we sent you rules and restrictions do
apply ok so it seems that the the left
is not going to give up on some of their
insane tactics with regard to attacking
folks on the right there's a couple of
stories that are really bad out today
apparently there's a man who's now been
arrested after threatening to kill Rand
Paul and his family with an axe so
things are going really well
around Paul of course last year was
badly injured when his neighbor tackled
him over a matter of politics supposedly
so Senator Paul said the man had
threatened to kill me and chop up my
family with an axe it's just horrendous
that we're having to deal with things
like this
now do I think by the way that you know
this is regular Democrat my guess is
probably not so I think that the guy who
shot the Congressional baseball game was
a regular Democrat I don't think so I
don't think there's any indicator that
that was the case but there is no
question that the Democrats are
deliberately raising the temperature in
the country and they're treating people
as heroes for confronting other people
in public right not by protesting now by
making an appointment for discussion not
by speaking out but by harassing people
in public so this is the most polite
harassment that I've seen and still it's
not I think a very good precedent Scott
Pruett was at a restaurant the EPA Chief
Scott produce at a restaurant and a
woman comes up with her child and
decides to lecture him on why he should
resign
every night
my son
okay you know I'm not sure why this is a
good thing so people are treating this
is like this is a great thing she's
confronting Scott Pruett in public I'm
not sure why not sure why like do I
think it's the end of the world I don't
you know I've had discussions with
people on politics in public before but
do I think that it's good for the
country that this sort of thing is
happening on a more regular basis not
particularly cuz I don't think that this
woman is interested in engaged engaging
in discussion I think that the reason
there's a camera on her right now is
because she wants a viral video of her
telling off Scott Pruett and that's what
we've become or a country of people who
want videos of ourselves telling people
off and and none of this is particularly
good now there's a lot of people today
who are making fun of alan dershowitz Oh
Alan Dershowitz I had him when he had
Dersch when I was at Harvard Law School
and dersh is a Democrat right he's been
a lifelong Democrat he voted for Barack
Obama I believe twice and now he has
been somewhat friendly to president
Trump's to president from sort of legal
strategy and he's written a piece about
why it is that so many people on the
Left are now sort of excising him from
their lives here's what he writes and
he's getting made fun up for this he
writes congresswoman Maxine Waters
recently told her supporters to hound
president Trump's cabinet members
wherever they find them they're not
gonna be able to go to a restaurant
they're not gonna be able to stop at a
gas station they're not gonna be able to
shop at a department store the people
are gonna turn on them they're gonna
protest they're gonna absolutely harass
them waters does not speak for all
Democrats or liberals nor do those who
through Sarah Huckabee Sanders out of a
red hen restaurant neither do those who
have harassed other members of the Trump
administration but these rude extremists
are a symptom of the times the divisions
have gotten so bad that many on both
sides refused to speak or listen to
people on the other side either you're
for Trump or against him and that is all
some people need to know to make
judgments about you now obviously I
think that logic has permeated every
side right you're either for Trump or
you're against him when I was on Bill
Maher he said that right to start the
interview he said you know these days
you're either a Republican or a Democrat
I'm a Democrat when he said that I was
on Team treason which is just
demonstrative of the fact that he knows
number one nothing
about me and number two of the of the
polarization in our politics desertion
which is right about that and then he
gets into his personal experience and
this is where he's getting mocked he
says I know this because I've
experienced this firsthand on Martha's
Vineyard I'm not a trump supporter nor
am i member of the Trump administration
I strongly and publicly opposed his
immigration policies ranging from the
travel ban that was upheld by the
Supreme Court to the zero tolerance
policy that led to the separation of
parents and children at the border I
opposed other Republican policies as
well I voted for and contributed
handsomely to Hillary Clinton but I've
defended Trump's civil liberties along
with those of all Americans just as I
would have defended Hillary Clinton's
civil liberties had she been elected and
subjected to efforts of impeachment or
prosecution and then he says I'm a
liberal Democrat in politics but a
neutral Civic libertarian when it comes
to the Constitution but that is not good
enough for some of my old friends and
Martha's Vineyard says says Alan
Dershowitz is for them it is enough that
what I have said about the Constitution
might help Trump so they are shunning me
and trying to ban me from their social
life on Martha's Vineyard one of them an
academic and a distinguished university
has told people he would not attend any
dinner or party to which I was invited
he and others have demanded trigger
warnings so they can be assured of
having safe spaces in which they will
not encounter me or my ideas others have
said they will discontinue contributions
to organizations that sponsor my talks
this is all familiar to me since I lived
through McCarthyism in the 1950s when
lawyers who represented alleged
communists on civil libertarian grounds
were shown some of those lawyers and
victims of McCarthyism lived on Martha's
Vineyard I never thought I'd see
McCarthyism come to Martha's Vineyard
but I have I wonder if the professor who
refuses to listen to anything I have to
say also treats a student similarly what
he listened to a student who actively
supported Trump what about one who
simply supported a civil liberties okay
so people are making fun of him because
Martha's Vineyard is very wealthy and if
true if Dershowitz is getting shunned on
Martha's Vineyard Oh play the world's
smallest violin and sort of how the
logic goes but I'd like to point out the
counter logic of left so the left itself
has said that it is a refusal of human
dignity it is a refusal of human dignity
for me and my synagogue not to perform
your same-sex wedding right it is a
violation of your personal dignity for
me personally not to approve of your
behavior in any way not just with regard
to sex with regard to anything for me to
withhold my approval of you is a denial
of your self-esteem and it's a it's an
imposition on your life and then the
same people will mock Alan Dershowitz
for saying listen I used to be able to
invited all these dinner parties I said
that Trump has civil rights and now I'm
not invited
dinner parties the point that Dershowitz
is making is not that he's seeing some
sort of brutal government crackdown the
point that he's making and I think it's
well taken is that intolerance in our
nation has reached a supreme extreme
where nobody is even listening to one
another anymore he'd prefer for these
utopian schemes to play out one way or
the other
so there's particularly trauma left
where they believe that Donald Trump is
going to be removed from office through
a deus ex machina there's going to be
something that happens the ghosts
outside there will be a god outside the
Machine who will intervene stick his
hand in and trumple no longer be
President and if you don't believe that
well you don't belong in our religious
clique and he's not wrong about that
Dershowitz when he says this wenzer true
it says that he's being excised the only
thing that he's wrong about is that this
is something new this isn't new at all
this was happening during the Bush
administration every Republican that I
know when they go to a Thanksgiving
dinner he's shunned by their Democratic
relatives I know very few Republicans
who have actually shunned their
Democratic relatives when they come over
for dinner there's a reason that
conservatives avoid bringing up politics
when they're in the context of their of
their family events whereas Democrats
have no problem doing it whatsoever
people on the Left are constantly
bringing up politics and family dinners
because they understand that
conservatives tend to be more tolerant
polls show this by the way the
conservatives tend to interact more with
people on the Left than people on the
Left tend to act interact with
conservatives but then the mockery of
Alan Dershowitz that oh he's rich and oh
he's Jewish you know he teaches at
Harvard Law therefore why is he
complaining about how people treat him
this is coming from the same people who
whine non-stop about how they are
treated by people to whom they have no
right to affection and it's it's
mind-boggling Lee mind-bogglingly
hypocritical but perfectly within line
with how the left thinks which is that
they have all these rights from you but
you have no rights from them the answer
is we none of us have a right to love
from from anybody right none of us have
that but we all do have I think an
obligation to civility an obligation of
civility and that is going by the
wayside in pretty obvious fashion so in
just a second I want to talk about that
political divide a little bit more first
I want to say thanks to our sponsors
over at Birch gold so 21 trillion
dollars in counseling that's our
national debt that's money we owe other
countries it's greater than the entire
economic output of the United States if
your entire life savings is tied to the
US dollar you might want to ask yourself
what happens if the Chinese start
selling American bonds because of our
debt that we're not paying off gold is a
hedge
inflation it's a hedge against
uncertainty and stability with precious
metals it is a safe haven against that
sort of uncertainty my savings plan is
diversified and yours should be as well
the company that I trust with precious
metal purchases is Birch gold group and
right now thanks to a little-known IRS
tax law you can even move your IRA or
eligible 401k into an IRA backed by
physical gold and silver which is
perfect for people who want to protect
their hard-earned retirement savings
from any future geopolitical uncertainty
so look back historically when the
bottom falls out of everything else
Gold tends to safeguard the money you've
got Birch gold group has thousands of
satisfied customers countless five-star
reviews an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau and you already know
about birch Gold's free information kit
for a limited time qualified purchases
can earn up to an additional ten
thousand bucks in precious metals for
free through July 31st to find out if
your purchase qualifies contact Birch
gold right now that's birchgold.com /ban
talk to a birch Kohl's rep mention I
sent you that's birchgold.com slash man
do it now the offer only runs until July
31st terms and limitations do apply ask
your sales representative for details
ok so speaking we're going to talk about
the political polarization first go over
to Daly where calm and subscribe $9.99 a
month get to a subscription of daily
wire calm when you get that subscription
get the rest of my show live that's the
rest of the Andrew Clavin show live
Michael Moses show live get to be part
of our mailbag on Fridays also when we
have episodes of the conversation or
special episodes like we did last night
with Jordan Peterson then you get to ask
questions if you are a member and for
$99 a year you get the annual
subscription which is even better
because you get this leftist year's hot
or cold tumbler which has been
automatically refilling day by day as
the Supreme Court's election grows ever
closer to replace Anthony Kennedy go
check that out right now also subscribe
over at our YouTube or our or our iTunes
channel make sure that you leave us a
review we always do appreciate it we're
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
so the extremism of the left is on full
display the reason they feel fully
justified in treating people badly is
because they feel that you are an
inferior human being and again I don't
think there's anything new I think that
that Alan Dershowitz has just been
mugged by reality when he complains
about this stuff I don't think that
anything has changed I really don't
think anything has changed so I'll take
for an example joss whedon so joss
whedon has been a nut for a long time
and now joss whedon tweets out this
today hey far-right gonna beat you not
gonna start a war not gonna shoot you
run you over threatened your kids gonna
beat you with passionate compassion with
journalism activism the law with votes
your rage is fear our rage is love our
state is united happy fourth it's that
last it's that second to last line that
really is telling like I'm glad that
he's not gonna start a war by the way if
people on the Left tried to start a war
with people on the right they should
think about who has all the guns in the
country right now but that second last
line they're our rage is love your rage
is fear our rage is love no your age is
not love your rage is rage your rage is
rage and I think that we live in an era
of politics where anger is seen as
authenticity that if you are not rageful
if you are not screaming at the moon if
you're not baying like a hound to people
then that means that you're not
passionate enough we can automatically
throw out your opinion it means you're
not authentic the most authentic
politicians are the ones who yell and
scream at people those are the ones that
we really should follow all the way down
the primrose path those are the people
we also engage with the left believes
this right the left believes that they
did not fight hard to get hard enough
against President Trump that Hillary
Clinton was too civil to President Trump
and that's why they need to go yell at
people in restaurants that's why they
need to attack people at gas stations
that's letting the mob people because if
they do that then maybe these
Republicans will be taught their lesson
that's not how any of this works you
want to convince people must vote for
President Trump who voted for him last
time you need to stop calling them
racist you're gonna need to stop
threatening their families you're gonna
need to stop with the are rages fear
routine our rage is love routine your
rage is not love your rage is clearly
fear your rage is obviously fear this is
not righteous indignation this is this
is just anger it's just pure I'll anger
directed at the president and directed
at the president supporters and the
reason you can tell this is because of
the disproportionate response to
everything Trump does if they were just
angry when Trump does something wrong
then
maybe I'd get it right if they just got
angry over Charlottesville and I'd say
okay but that's not the day that's not
the deal
every time Trump does anything they lose
their minds any time he performs any
constitutional function they suggest
that it's legitimately the end of the
world that we're watching right now is a
breakdown in real-time who we are
watching the the apocalyptic politics
that are going to end the country and I
just don't understand it I just don't
understand why anybody would look at
America right now and think that we're
living in an apocalypse
we're legitimately living in heaven if
you were born and not if you if you were
transported from 1920 you ripped down
Winkley go to sleep in let's say 19 1920
let's pick 1917 is the middle of World
War one okay and two years aways the
influenza epidemic the your ways an
influenza epidemic that's gonna kill
legitimately hundreds of thousands of
people across the world and you're
living in 1919 17 1918 and you go to
sleep and you wake up and it's 2018 we
fast forward a hundred years and it's
2018 you would think you had died and
gone to heaven you would you would think
you were dead and you'd gone to heaven
that you died in the influenza epidemic
and now you were in heaven that's how
good things are right now okay the fact
it not for everybody obviously they're
suffering obvious there are people
having a tough time but the average
citizen of the United States has a car a
microwave central air-conditioning a
piece of hardware that they carry around
in their hand that has more computing
power than NASA had when they sent
somebody to the moon okay the in walking
around with instant access to
information and entertainment have to go
to a movie theater anymore and drop
money at a movie theater instead you've
got this information that's available to
you at every moment of the day you you
can court you can FaceTime with your
kids when you're 3,000 miles away and
and not just that the levels of violence
in American society are at record lows
they're not at record highs okay then we
had a murder epidemic that took place
basically from 1960 to 1994 and started
dropping then and it's continued to drop
okay but you can live in your
neighborhood depending on your
neighborhood the most most neighborhoods
in the United States you go to sleep at
night and you're not deeply worried that
somebody's gonna break in your house and
murder you or they your house is gonna
get burned down or there's gonna be a
riot outside hey that's think about the
progression in New York City alone New
York City was one of the most violent
places
in America New York City is now one of
the safest places in America America has
has made heaven a reality at least in so
far as anyone in the past would have
thought and we are looking at it we are
seeing a hell and maybe that's because
we've got the wrong frame of mind that's
because we're not comparing ourselves to
the past we're not even comparing
ourselves to what we could be we are
comparing ourselves to utopia that
doesn't exist but only exists in your
mind and we're comparing ourselves to a
political system that has never been in
tried that has never been that has never
been really attempted without leaving a
lot of people dead and we're comparing
ourselves to this phantom that doesn't
exist in reality and then we're
declaring that we have come up short I
mean that that's that the only way I can
explain this anger because anger it
seems to me is coming out of frustration
and the only reason the Democrats would
be frustrated in a world where same-sex
marriage is legal abortion on demand is
legal and they've got everything they
want in terms of state intervention in a
social safety net basically they're
looking around they're saying this is
hell this is hell maybe it's just that
they were so used to being on top for so
long that when when the American people
said hold up a sec let's throw the
brakes on and let's appreciate what's
happened in the United States and maybe
let's maybe let's think about whether
we've gone too far in some areas that
they were so panicked about that they
saw utopia is something lost another
frustrated and angry whatever it is it's
delusional and that delusion is leading
to a psychic break among a lot of
hardcore Democrats that is going to lead
the country in in worse and worse
directions okay meanwhile I want to talk
to you about this really funny study so
one of the things that I think is really
funny is that the left is insistent that
science is not a thing really there are
a lot of folks on the Left who believe
that real science is a manifestation of
the patriarchy and that biological
differences are really not biological
differences particularly between men and
women they are oh they are all socially
constructed so the left wants to hold
that gender identity is fully biological
that if you're a man who believes you
are a woman that is fully biological and
there is no active choice involved
whatsoever but it's also socially
constructed gender it's how gender is
socially constructed but your gender
identity is biological if you can square
that circle then congratulations to you
because you are a you are either
incredibly stupid or incredibly smart
because that makes no sense at all but
it turns out that biology has some
things to say about differences between
the sexes and those
don't always cut in favor of feminist
notions about the differences between
the sexes so there's a study that the
Daily Mail reports on today say women
are more attracted to men who are sexist
because they think they are more willing
to protect them provide for them and
commit to a relationship scientists say
so poor poor feminists men who think
that they were going to think that they
were going to get some because they were
because they were wearing the I am a
feminist t-shirt it turns out that you
are less that you are less prone to to
be the the obvious victors in natural
selection than the guy who just says men
are men women are women and men's job is
to defend women you know why women kind
of like that because women think that
men's job is to defend women even women
who believe that men's job is not to
defend women believe that men's job is
to defend women all the same feminists
in the meets you movement who think the
men are predators then yell at men who
didn't do enough to protect women not
men who are rapists men who didn't
protect women enough why because they
understand there's a social obligation
that is real a moral obligation for men
to defend women in a stronger way than
men defend men men don't defend men as
strongly as men defend women just a
reality and women like that oops so it
says men who are considered to be sexist
in a well-meaning way for example if
they're chivalrous
or think women need a man to protect
them maybe more attractive even though
women find these men patronizing and can
feel undermined by them they're more
likely to want to couple up with them
than with men who don't give them
special treatment right feminists still
want men to pick up the bill when they
go to coffee researchers say women may
be hardwired to think the benefits of
being with a kind but sexist man
outweigh the downsides the scientists
maintain that despite romantic and
flattering elements of the relationship
even well-meaning sexism reinforces the
idea that women are inferior okay this
is the part of the study that's done it
really if women really believe that man
opening a door for them means that they
are inferior that's because women have a
complex that cannot be cured by a change
in men's social status a I don't know a
secure woman on earth and feels terrible
that a man opened a door for them it
says even women who consider themselves
strong feminists show the same
preferences in the study by British and
US researchers so it's not internalized
misogyny ladies okay it you can be as
feminist as you want to be and it turns
out you still want to do it he's going
to protect and defend a family you know
why because women are built to have kids
with men and men are built to have kids
with
and women are built to need protection
by men from other men hey this is this
is not just among human beings okay this
is true among the chimpanzees the
reality is that dominant males are not
just physically dominant they are also
protective of their brood scientists
from the University of Kent and Iowa
State University carried out five tests
to explore the theory that women are
more attracted to what they call
benevolent sexist benevolent means
well-meaning are kind experts to find
the sexism as men who for example think
women are more delicate or should be
cherished or looked after by a man okay
I don't know why that sexist women are
more physically delicate as a general as
a general sort that is a biological
truth
women are more physically delicate on
average that doesn't mean that I am that
I am less physically delicate than
Serena Williams okay Serena Williams
could beat the crap out of me but the
reality is that on average men are
stronger than women women are more
physically delicate than men duh sorry
to break it okay and also that women why
is it sexist to say women should be
cherished what I'm just confused would
you rather I said women shouldn't be
cherished and I guess we just treat
women like the garbage I treated all my
male friends like men treat each other
like crap are you kidding
like you've ever been in a group of men
all they do is sock each other in the
nuts and talk crash trash to each other
like that's really what guys do it seems
to me that women should be pretty happy
that men and cherish them but and that's
not sexist that's because women should
be cherished because women are more
special than men and they do require a
certain level of protection they say
that sexist attitudes were the norm for
decades this is shifted in recent years
but heterosexual women's preferences for
partners may not be moving on as quickly
why because it's embedded in biology the
researchers test found women are more
attracted to men who have benevolent
sexist attitudes and actions and they
are the men who treat them as equals or
don't give them special treatment so
this is really really funny so even even
feminists are by the way it says that
women are also attracted to get ready
for it popularity money muscles and
intelligence oh you mean like the basics
of natural selections still hold for
human women I can't believe it but I
guess we're all supposed to pretend that
all this is a social construct that
really what what men want is a soy soy
drinking pajama boy who sits in his
mother's basement all day and reads
feminist literature that's that that's
what that's what women are really
looking for yeah well good luck with
that dudes really solid luck with that
okay
time for some things I like and then
some things that I hate so things I like
today so let's do let's do a movie so a
quiet place this is a movie with John
Krasinski who's in and directed by John
Krasinski as well with Emily Blunt John
Krasinski is very good in the movie
Emily Blunt is terrific because she's
really a she's a first-rate actress you
know when I think of actresses who are
the best working today I think Emily
Blunt is probably the best actress
working today I think she's better than
Natalie Portman I think that she is it's
like significantly better than Natalie
Portman who I think is wildly overrated
I think she's better than Kate Winslet
who I really do like as an actress Emily
Blunt is just terrific
this is a very kind of small horror film
it was it's only about an hour and a
half long which is how long movies
should be and yet I see you're saying
Amy Adams but no I think I would prefer
Emily Blunt I do like Amy Adams as an
actress she's very versatile but Emily
Blunt is a better actress I think but
this is a movie the basic premise of it
it's what they call a high concept
horror film so the basic premise of it
is that these aliens invade earth we
don't know how they got here or what
they've done to the rest of humanity but
they are blindness they can't see
anything but they can hear pretty much
everything so if you make noise then
they will hunt you down so it's about
this family that sort of lives on a farm
and the one of the kids has hearing
difficulty so all the people can speak
sign language this obviously helps
protect them against the aliens it's
it's really atmospheric and really
creepy but it's also quite meaningful
pro-life and ProGuard so I mean I doubt
that they meant this when they wrote the
film but it is a pro-life pro-gun film
and one of the basic issues is that as
this is happening you know and you're
not allowed to make noise the Emily
Blunt who's the wife in the film is
pregnant and there's never a thought
about like should she have the baby or
not she's going to have the baby well
babies make a lot of noise and so
obviously this is a serious issue for
the film so here's a little bit of the
preview
[Music]
like they pray before meals like it
it's a really conservative film yeah
there's not a lot of talking because the
movie doesn't have a lot of dialogue
like what what it's the yeah it's never
never make a sound as sort of a sort of
the slogan it the movie begins with just
this horrifying scene I mean it's in the
preview um it's the first three minutes
of the film this is horrifying scene
where one of the kids make some noise
and an alien basically kills the kid
it's it's really really upsetting but
unlike other horror films that sort of
treat you know the death of children is
almost a fun aspect of the horror film
like it's treated with actual
sensitivity it's treated as a real you
know a real thing that tears the family
apart
it's a very good movie it's a very good
movie like I'm very impressed it made a
ton of money at the box office um and I
think one of the reasons that it made a
ton money of the box office is twofold
one horror films right now are doing hot
hot stuff the box office because to
experience a horror film in in a
communal setting is very different from
watching it individually so when you
watch it on your phone you watch it at
home
it's not quite as scary you watch it in
a theater with a bunch of people who are
reacting the same way that you're
reacting comedies and horror films are
gonna do better at the box office
big action flicks that have you know
obviously you require a big screen for
them is a different thing but I think
horror films are doing huge business
because it still requires sort of a
communal feeling them but beyond that
the movie did really well because the
movie is tightly constructed okay the
movie is not a wasted it's not wasted
space and also it doesn't it doesn't
make some it doesn't make some political
actor the bad guy it's really more about
the solidity of the family itself and
the family unit the importance of the
family in a really good movie go check
it out a quiet place John Krasinski who
directed it and did he write it as well
he I'm not sure but he's the star of it
with his what his actual real-life wife
Emily one okay time for a thing that I
hate
so Starbucks will never be left alone
ever Starbucks will never be left alone
so now that they supposedly borrowed a
black guy from a bathroom in
Philadelphia a story which I still have
significant doubts about because again
there are many cameras in that Starbucks
the person behind the counter the
barista who is supposedly the evil
racist turns out to be an sjw you know
woman in any case they've now shut down
their restaurant for three hours to
retrain everybody in implicit bias which
is a bunch of crap anyway now Starbucks
advisers say that the company's anti
racial bias training in response to the
arrest of two black men in a store in
Philadelphia is not enough according to
Z C McAlister over at the Daily wire
they're proposing a civil rights audit
of the company to make equity its
number-one concern
so former Starbucks CEO Howard Schultz
contacted Heather McGee of the Equality
advocacy group group demos and Sheeran
fo eyeful of the n-double a-c-p legal
defense and education fund after the
arrest in May for advice always a
mistake because they returned with
advice and what is the advice the advice
is spend a lot of money on us right they
want a top-to-bottom civil rights audit
because Starbucks when I think Jim Crow
I think Starbucks when I think Bull
Connor I think that barista behind the
counter with seven earrings three
tattoos and a gender binary and a gender
non-binary identity I think that that
person is the is the new that is the new
avid that that's George Wallace back
there I know and I see that person I
think man that's it that's personally
sick dogs on black people if that person
could get a chance if that if that non
gender binary bisexual pansexual
tattooed hasn't held a job except for
being a barista among diverse peoples
that that person that's the guy I'm
really afraid of that guys John C
Calhoun back there so here they say they
say that this this should include a top
to bottom civil rights audit more
resources for employees encountering
customers with mental health and
addiction problems and the creation of a
customer Bill of Rights to be posted at
each store a customer Bill of Rights you
have the right to be the right to be
served as the customer as the as the
restaurant wishes to serve you you do
not have a customer Bill of Rights
that's always you have a customer Bill
of Rights is so stupid you have a market
choice when you have a market choice you
don't have a customer Bill of Rights a
Bill of Rights is necessary against the
government because the government can
actually impede on your rights you don't
have a right
- anything from the restaurant if you
walk in and you say I have a right to
your food the restaurant rightly would
say no you don't you didn't pay for that
food but the idea that you have rights
against other American citizens when it
comes to their private business
transactions is just inane
they say that they they found some
improvements these people than in the
Starbucks understanding of the nature of
unconscious bias but they decided that
they need a more rigorous evaluation so
I guess that we're going to actually put
all the Starbucks baristas in rooms like
clockwork orange' gonna pry their eyes
open with the with the with the metal
thingies and then we're going to make
them watch over and over 12 years of
slave until they understand that slavery
has to do with coffee or something and
then and says that the policy manuals
need to be overhauled to prioritize
equality throughout the company culture
and clearly direct employees on managing
customer relations including how to
respond to incidences of discrimination
bias and harassment and then this is the
problem you know what Starbucks deserves
this okay they had this coming so I
don't hate it that much because
Starbucks decided they were going to dip
a toe into the pool of the sjw's and now
they're going to they're going to just
move into this that they're now going to
just move into this sort of biased
retraining a full-time fine you dip your
toe in the water there's that video that
came out of this woman who was putting
her hands in the water near a shark and
a shark bit her finger and pulled her
into the water and everybody's like oh
it was shocking okay that that video is
a metaphor for Starbucks Starbucks
decided to put their finger into the
water with the sjw's and the SJW just
drag them under now they're ripping off
their digits one by one
so enjoy Starbucks I hope that that
coffee is some solace to you all right
we'll be back here tomorrow with all the
latest updates i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah
of era the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2018